Disease-causing microbes continue
to evolve, evading host defenses,
defeating drugs, and
spreading antibiotic resistance.
Recently emerged threats,
such as the Zika and Ebola,
are certain to evolve in ways
that can be hard to predict.
Scientists must work with dangerous strains
--sometimes
even engineering new ones--
to understand these bugs.
The next president will need to make sure
these labs are secure,
and get the country
prepared for a pandemic,
while figuring out how to encourage
the development of new antibiotics.
The advent of CRISPR allows
unprecedented precision
editing of genomes.
This could lead to cures for disease and better
pest control,
but also ethical and
regulatory challenges
The next president will
likely have to contend
with the technique’s potential
to edit human embryos
and how this approach is
regulated in plants and animals.
Around the world, sea levels are rising
a few millimeters a year on average
But, all sea level rise is local.
US East Coast sea levels are rising
at double the global rate,
and at triple the average in Virginia.
The next president will have
to wrestle with protecting
billions of dollars in infrastructure
and helping seaside communities prepare
and adapt to rising waters.
Brain health touches us from cradle to grave,
and when brain disease strikes,
the costs—personal and
budgetary—are staggering.
As the US population ages,
Alzheimer’s and
dementia are on the rise.
At the other end of life,
the prevalence of autism and
learning disabilities has jumped.
The new president will have to plan for a
ramp-up in spending on brain disease
that will put a squeeze on federal
health care budgets.
And decide how high a priority to place on
spending for basic brain research.
AI is already having an impact on society.
Products and services from self-driving cars
to systems that guide
medical care and treatment
could bring major benefits,
including increased productivity and
fewer deaths from traffic accidents.
But letting machines make their own decisions
also raises profound ethical,
legal, and regulatory questions.
The administration will need
to keep a close eye
on AI’s impact on the economy,
workforce, and national security.
When experts calculate risk,
they rely on statistics,
but ordinary people tend
to rely on their guts.
Both approaches have their pitfalls.
Misperception of risk can push a president
to overreact to lesser threats
and underreact to greater problems.
And how a president communicates
with the public about risk
can mean the difference between
sowing panic and maintaining calm.
The next president will face a long list of
policy decisions surrounding known risks,
including terrorist attacks, foreign conflicts,
domestic crime and violence,
flu pandemics, and natural disasters.